the jaguars uh they are in position to
draft trevor lawrence with the first
overall pick and shireen
same conversation we had about russell
wilson what is your philosophical
preference the guy who you hope will be
a sure thing
or
all the other lottery tickets you could
get for him and the example that i
always share now last year if the
bengals had said yes to the dolphins and
moved down to number five they could
have taken justin herbert and a bunch of
other stuff and they'd be in better
shape right now setting aside the torn
acl for joe burrow they'd be in better
shape right now with justin herbert plus
xyz on top of whatever the dolphins were
offering that's what the jaguars need to
ask themselves are we sufficiently
convinced that trevor lawrence is a sure
thing that we're going to say no to all
offers that would allow us to get a
lower first round pick address our
quarterback needs and still get more
stuff
that's that's the question will they say
yes or will they say no to whatever
offer someone inevitably makes and i'm
convinced someone will and i think it'll
be the panthers if they don't get
deshaun watson i think they move on to
trevor lawrence and they try to get the
jaguars to slide down to eight and let
carolina move up to number
one i think first mike it depends on how
you feel about those other quarterbacks
i do think that this guy is the the
the most blue chip quarterback we've
seen probably since andrew luck but when
you look at the the recent history of
the nfl the best quarterbacks in the nfl
right now were not top five picks they
weren't and and you go check it out they
they weren't top five picks so if you
like one of those other guys i can
absolutely see the jaguars listen to an
offer
getting a buku of draft picks which they
need i looked at this roster and i'm
just like wow how many of these players
do you build around and there just
aren't very many now they've got a ton
of cap space we know the most cap space
in the nfl whatever it is they're going
to have a ton of cap space to go help
themselves in free agency pick out the
right free agency in your
free agents and you're definitely going
to be better next year but the draft is
key too and the more picks you have the
more chances you have they have a ton of
picks now but i still think mike if you
like one of those other guys almost as
well as you like trevor lawrence you
have to at least listen you have to at
least consider it you can't just pick up
the phone and say no
there's the football side of it too and
then there's the business side of it and
obviously the hiring of urban meyer
tells me that shad khan the owner of the
team is currently in the sizzle and
splash business so from that perspective
none of the other guys is trevor
lawrence trevor lawrence is the guy
who's going to be the draw now there's
two ways to look at it you can say we
already have the sizzle with urban meyer
we can go football and not business
decision with the quarterback or you say
we're all in with these business
decisions that will fill stadiums we'll
worry about whether or not we're any
good later we got urban meyer we got
trevor lawrence and people are going to
want to flock to watch us play in
jacksonville and in london so
look
owners try to act like they're not
involved in these picks they're involved
in these picks they're involved they
they they are involved and shad khan may
have already decided
no way no how are we giving up trevor
lawrence whatever someone offers us we
will say no and my guess is same way the
bengals did it last year i think the
jaguars do it this year they want to
give it a try with the first overall
pick they want to see what trevor
lawrence can do pair him up with urban
meyer if it doesn't work you know what
i'll be in position to do it again
before too long yeah
yeah that's exactly right mike and and i
agree with you i mean the key this year
frankly is filling stadiums jaguars were
second in the nfl this year to the
cowboys in attendance they will fill up
that stadium if they're allowed to fill
up that stadium which you know you had
the report today i think that their the
nfl plans for full stadiums or thinks
they're going to have them by september
that's great news for all these teams
particularly for the jaguars who have
not had that in recent seasons they've
had a lot of empty seats they're going
to fill up that stadium with people
wanting to come watch trevor lawrence
and see urban meyer
thinking that he can build a winner in
the nfl just like he did at the
university of the florida just down the
street from where jacksonville is they
think he can do that again in
jacksonville mike
the asterisk on all of that is the
political climate where a stadium is
located places like new york
massachusetts pennsylvania california
may take a little more time but florida
and texas it's going to be
open the turnstiles and let everybody
come in by the time we get to september
especially given where people think the
pandemic will be if folks get the
vaccine if folks continue to be smart
about wearing masks we could be at a
point where a lot of this is behind us
by then wouldn't that be great if it
happens all right let's play a little
game here
with uh
one in and one out we're each going to
pick a guy that we think
will join the team and a guy that we
think will leave the team or at least
someone we would add and someone would
get rid of no trevor lawrence for this
though what trevor lawrence is set aside
but other than that shireen give me
somebody that you think will be part of
this jaguars team who currently isn't
either via free agency or the draft
i think it's leonard williams i mean you
look at that defense they were 31st in
total defense they were 30th against the
run they need a guy like leonard
williams and when you look at the
defensive lineman he's at the top of
that list that free agent left they need
him they need big upgrades there he and
josh allen would pair well together it's
a significant
need for them he had the best season of
his career this year with 11 and a half
sacks he had 30 quarterback hits and 14
tackles for lost mice i just think he
would be a huge help
for jacksonville they have the most
money 79.6 million to go spend based on
180.5 million dollar cap maybe it goes
up a little bit from there but they have
plenty of money they can go get who they
want to get if the giants don't
franchise this guy mike i think they're
going to make every effort to sign
leonard williams
i'm going to immediately break the rule
that i just set by saying someone who
will be added via free agency or the
draft i'm going to say michael thomas a
trade with the new orleans saints the
saints unloading some cap space and
moving on from michael thomas maybe even
after june 2 again it doesn't matter
much to the new team since there won't
be the same off-season program but you
bring in a potent weapon for trevor
lawrence you reunite michael thomas with
urban meyer and that's been something
i've had a feeling about not that i know
anything about it i never know anything
life is easier that way but ever since
urban meyer took that job i thought you
know what the saints are it kind of
feels like they're at the end of their
rope with michael thomas would be a
perfect opportunity to trade thomas to
jet to the jaguars and put him back
together with urban meyer shireen
yeah no doubt about it mike i think that
would be a great move for them they need
to upgrade at the receiver position
that'd be perfect perfect and with the
receivers they have
they have a lot of twos
i got to be clear on this
this is just a throw the dart this is
not
not a report
we're not going to try to turn better
this is not a a bold prediction this is
not three first rounders plus christian
mccaffrey for sean watson this is just a
flat out wild crazy guess and nothing
more i promise you all right give me
somebody who's going to be gone
well the problem is i don't think the
jaguars are going to make any cuts mike
they don't need to there's no need to
they don't have a ton of players who who
have bad contracts now they've gotten
rid of most of those so the one guy you
look at that's a free agent that you
think well they could possibly resign is
cam robinson but i'm going gonna say cam
robinson walks out the door you know he
they picked him in the second round in
2017 he's been basically their starting
left tackle ever since then he did have
the ac l injury in 2018 so he didn't
play much that season but basically
they're starting left tackle started 47
of 64 regular season games
i think they'll go out and find an
upgrade on cam robinson cam robinson
should make quite a bit of money and
free agency there's better guys out
there for them to go up and upgrade and
whether that's in the draft doing it
that way or in free agency going and
getting say you know a trent williams or
somebody like that that's probably
better than cam robinson i think they
need to do that mike so i see cam
robinson leaving in free agency i don't
think the jaguars will make an offer for
him
if they're going to cut anybody they
need to cut tight end tyler eifert
they'll free up 3-4 million in cap space
that way another guy they need to move
on from and i think they could find some
sort of a trade market out there for him
i think it's important to move on from
gardner minshew that that ship has
sailed and it's not like he's going to
be a veteran presence that tremendously
helps trevor lawrence and he you know i
i like gardner mitchu's fire i like his
spirit i don't know that that fits with
what the jaguars are going to be looking
for in a backup quarterback there's two
kinds of backup quarterbacks you can
have the guy who's who thinks he's the
starter and is trying to compete to be
the starter or the guy who knows his
place is number two and is doing
everything he can to support the starter
i don't think minshu is suited for that
role and i think that's what the jaguars
need so
off with gardner minshew maybe get some
real value for him get more than the
sixth round pick then you gave up to get
him and and have a veteran there to be
the backup to trevor lawrence and help
him learn the ropes at the nfl level
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports